and i think about the fact that you're a
comedian and you
you have these
you have these roles you have you know
you're the cable guy which i do want to
hear by the way what it sounds like when
you're larry the cable guy versus
dan or versus any other character i'm
curious because i want people to
understand when you are larry the cable
guy versus not and maybe it's just in
the jokes but maybe it's in the accent
but also i'm thinking you make people
feel comfortable
and so you know you grew up
you know i mean from what i understand
you know your dad wasn't always the
easiest on you and
you know you you know comedy came in at
a young age and and i wonder if maybe
there's some level some like more
psychological sort of perspective where
you mold into your environment because
it makes people feel comfortable
oh absolutely you know
um comedy gave me confidence
i never really had a lot of confidence
and comedy gave me confidence because
when once you got on stage and you
started doing it
um you're not good at first but you
stick to it then all of a sudden you get
up and you you're in control of an
audience and
and you're making some people laugh and
all of a sudden a pretty girl comes up
and starts talking to you
it give then you get more and more
confidence i think that's why a lot of
times
later when i did the character it gave
me uh it
it gave me an opportunity to
kind of
um
do something
in another persona you know that made me
more comfortable
so when i started doing larry the cable
guy it's like i was just saying said to
somebody the other day i automatically
if i meet somebody for the first time or
i'm in a group of people for the first
time
i automatically
resort to and of course though somebody
will call me larry or whatever but it's
kind of a defense mechanism i feel more
comfortable
in a crowd of people going
hey what's going on y'all everybody hey
did y'all ever hit that birthday you
know uh oh yeah zipper last week please
you know and i just and i just naturally
talk that way because
i've had so much confidence doing that
that it kind of just
i ease into i eased into things a lot
better then you know an hour another
conversation
i'm back to my so i'm back to being me
and just talking like me but when i
first
when i first start in certain situations
that's how i start talking and it's
subconscious i mean i don't even do it
on purpose it's like my buddy called me
the other day my buddy brad ward from
sanford florida
he called me where i used to live in
sanford and
you know he was one of my buddies i grew
up with so he's real southern you know
and so
i was just talking to my wife like this
normal we're having a conversation brad
called and first thing she hears me do
is go hey what's up brad
no he ain't calling me but if he calls
you know tell him i got two of so just
you know whatever he needs to do
you know and i literally had this 15
minute conversation with my buddy brad
and i hung up and my wife said you know
you were in character for 15 minutes
i didn't even realize it it's just
that's how brad talks and he's my friend
and that's kind of like you know our
little group thing we got going so yeah
it's it's pretty crazy i really turn it
on
if it's somebody
that uh you know because i i was born in
nebraska but i grew up in the south
you know i grew up in florida which is
the south whether people want to believe
it or not
and depending on what part you're in
and so all my friends were southern you
know because i was a country kid i hung
out with the people that had livestock
and horses and cattle so
um
they were all very southern
so it's uh if i ever if i'm somewhere
here say if i'm somewhere just where i'm
at in lincoln and somebody will come up
and go hey larry man we're big fans man
we we've seen you down you know and they
got a southern accent i'll go
hey man i appreciate it where y'all from
and they'll tell me oh yeah you know we
spent time down there and
you know it just it just happens and i
subconsciously do it i don't do it just
because i'm trying to fake somebody out
i do it because it's just me it's just
that's what comes out of me
uh i think it makes me feel safer it
makes me feel
uh
more connected to the person
um
because i'll be honest i i really i
uh i didn't have a lot of confidence
when i was a kid and i built my
confidence through the character larry
the cable guy that enabled me to be able
to go on stage
in front of thousands of people
and tell jokes
uh and it and it so yeah it's really
helped me come out of my shell and be
able to talk to people with confidence
and
why weren't you confident i mean clearly
you're a friendly guy you're a funny guy
you're
you're an empathetic kind person which
because all you're you're really just
mirroring people so that's a very you
know that makes people feel really
comfortable so what was it what was it
about your childhood that wasn't that
didn't make you have confidence
well no it's just you know some kids
grow up they don't think they're good at
anything you and your mind think you're
good at something but you're scared to
try it for fear that you're not good at
it what happens if you failed
was there a punishment
no not at all if you got bad grades did
you come home no
i got it
i got bad grades because i was goof off
and i just never really tried no look i
know you get that look my dad was uh i
love my dad my dad was my dad i mean i
only have one dad
my dad was a preacher he was very strict
he was strict on some things he was not
strict on other things
uh but yeah he was very strict and he
wasn't a very good dad um i love him i
forgive him he's a human being now that
i'm older and i have kids i completely
understand where he's coming from
however he did things that i would never
do that i think
helped me to be a better father
you know
in other words
get rid of the violence
you know that kind of stuff
uh so i learned here's what i
learned here's what here's what you need
to do as kids
and as growing up you learn from your
elders and i've always learned from my
elders i've taken wonderful things from
my mom who has experienced so many
things through life at the age of 86
uh especially like going through this
pandemic and everybody's scared to walk
outside and everybody's scared to do
this
here's a woman that lived through small
pox and measles and hiding under desk
when they thought they were going to get
bombed by the
russians i mean she's and she was the
first one to go i don't get what
everybody's so scared about
it is you know what you live through
these things these are things that
happen every generation has and i get it
but yeah but uh so he just taught me how
to be i'm not a perfect dad but
uh i do my best and i learned
what we're supposed to do as we grow up
is learn from mistakes from other people
so you don't
do the same mistakes over again and
that's what i try to do in my life i try
to learn
from how i grew up and the mistakes that
my dad made i don't want to make those
mistakes
and so it made me a better father now a
lot of people don't do that they don't
think about it they don't learn and that
goes for everything it goes for
our government it goes for the way
people live their lives it goes for as
you can tell right now our government
never learns from the past they do the
same things over and over and over and
wonder why it's not working it helped in
my it helped me in comedy later on
because i was always the person that
could uh
pop out a funny joke or a one-liner when
i needed it to lighten the mood up a
little bit it really taught me timing
when to throw in a joke what kind of
joke is perfect for this situation
what joke might cross the line a little
bit so i really learned a lot
from from uh from that kind of stuff you
know well you you say that life you're
supposed to learn lessons and some
people don't learn them that's totally
true but i think the layer that most
people
don't get to
because i think it's the hardest one is
to say i love my dad like i as a dad now
can understand him
so
how did you get to that point because i
think that's the hardest is to get to
actually truly get to that point of
forgiveness of love and to be able to go
wow maybe you can even gather that it
probably came from his dad right and all
of a sudden now you go i'm not going to
keep this pattern going and i'm i i love
you
right well you know since you asked i'll
tell you you know um i'm a christian i
believe uh i'm not religious i'm a g i
try to follow
uh the bible and jesus as much as i can
we'll never do it obviously because
we're never going to be perfect
but
he taught me how to forgive